ạ
Đúng là nhiều cái chưa tắt thật Tắt bớt
thôi
Ok người ta bớt
nữa
nhưng tôi sợ tí mà tự nhiên thiếu ram
kiểu các thứ nó làm đơ máy tật
Ừ tắt cái này nghỉ luôn
này Đợi tí xem tiếng Uầy tiếng bị bé tí
luôn ạ Alo Alo ạ Các bạn nghe thấy rõ
không
ạ
cỡ lên mà
Ờ Đừng giật mình quá
lại ngồi cùng với nhau tâm kiểu chính xa
là tôi sẽ ngồi tâm sự các bạn sẽ phải
ngồi lắng nghe tôi nên tôi rất mong là
các bạn cũng ngồi tâm sự cùng tôi để
mình gọi như nh mình sẽ sự tương tác hai
chiều chứ không phải một chiều đúng
không
Thực ra tôi nghĩ là tôi tôi Thực ra tôi
thích hát đấy Tôi không nghĩ là tôi hát
hay nhưng là tôi được cái hay hát
Ờ tôi không ngại khi mà hát đâu nhưng mà
dạ n nhỉ
ờ không ý định là kiểu kênh của tôi về
sau sẽ
sẽ như nào nhé Ừ cũng có thể cũng thể
hôm nào hứng lên có thể sẽ quay lại một
cái gì gì đó
nhưng mà tôi không ý định là
Ờ đang in người khác hát đữa ngại á
Không kiểu
Ờ mọi người có xem lại mà bây giờ V ví
dụ nhá ví dụ Tôi vừa đi làm cả ngày về
tôi phải tranh thủ ngủ một tí để tôi
xong rồi tôi dậy để
tôi có thể tỉnh táo như bây giờ để ngồi
dậy học kiểu các thứ thứ như này nhưng
có thể nhiều người
sẽ không cần phải gấp như tôi thì có thể
kiểu về ăn uống nghỉ ngơi Nói chung là
khi mà hứng lên thì có thể Xem lại video
V sau thì chủ yếu là mấy ông nhìn người
lượng người xem trực tiếp thì có thể
không nhiều lắm Nhưng mà tôi thấy là
lượng người xem ấy thì cũng lên đâu đấy
tầm Ờ hơn trăm đấy Nên là nên là
rồi Đương nhiên là cái cái khóa này nó
nâng cao hơn n sẽ kén người xem hơn nên
là cũng nói chung là nó cũng có cái hay
có cái giờ của nó tôi không thể dạy các
bạn cơ bản mãi
được Hôm trước là tôi nhớ tôi để cái
link này ở đây để các bạn có thể nghe
qua Podcast ở bên spum này rồi Ờ C này
một câu hỏi đúng quan trọng hơn vạn câu
hỏi trả lời theo sau
đấy đã khá là kiểu
ờ
ờ đại khái thì tiêu đề nó nói tất cả rồi
và tôi cũng từng nói mấy ông rồi đó
là chúng ta phải dồn hết tâm huyết để
trả lời à Để hỏi một câu hỏi có tâm thì
sẽ được trả lời một câu trả lời có tâm
Ờ tôi thấy rất nhiều bạn hỏi rất hay
cũng có rất nhiều bạn chưa biết
hỏi các bạn tôi Tôi nghĩ là các bạn tìm
đến kênh tôi chắc là cũng đều gọi là
cũng cũng phải là tò mò cũng kiểu xem
kênh này có gì và cũng thậm chí là cũng
cảm thấy ở ở lại được thì chắc là cũng
cảm thấy là kênh cũng có tí phù hợp
nghĩa là chỉ là cũng h học hỏi đi Giả sử
thế chứ chắc chắn là phải ở lại nghe tôi
tấu hài rồi vì kênh này có phải kênh tấu
hài đâu đấy thì thì cái việc ham học hỏi
đấy là ham học nhưng mà chưa chắc là Ham
hỏi vì các bạn hỏi không đủ nhiều Tôi
thấy là thực ra chưa đủ nhiều đâu Cho dù
tôi thấy à các bạn có hỏi nhá Tôi thấy
đang hỏi trên discord xong rồi nhắn tin
hỏi riêng có nhưng mà thấy vẫn chưa đủ
nhiều đâu bởi vì à
đấy thì so với cái lượng người theo dõi
tôi hiện tại cứ giả sử là hơn nghìn
người đi thì đá lẽ là Nếu giả sử mà ham
hỏi chắc là tôi không có đủ tay để mà
trả lời được hết đến bây giờ tôi vẫn tự
tin là tôi trả lời được hết thì chứng tỏ
là các bạn chưa hỏi đủ nhiều rồi đúng
không ạ
Ờ có thể đương nhiên là các bạn sẽ thấy
tôi chỉ là một trong số kiểu trăm người
các bạn theo dõi chẳng quan trọng không
không đáng để hỏi vân vân Nhưng nhưng mà
ý tôi là
Ừ những lúc mà Tôi thấy các bạn hỏi thì
có những bạn là fer ấy các bạn vẫn thực
sự là kiểu vẫn hỏi hơi hời hợt tí toàn
bộ những cái kiến thức mà mình
à mình hỏi đôi khi là có trên mạng có
sẵn rồi giống như hôm trước tôi bảo là
có thể hỏi chat VT hoặc là Google nó có
nhiều đấy bây giờ Google cũng thích hợp
ai rồi mà Thì
mình nếu đặc biệt là nếu mình ở Dân công
nghệ mình phải khả năng tự học và rất là
tốt không phải là tự học ở đây là không
không được hỏi nhá Tôi dùng chity liên
tục gần như là cũng đồng nghĩa việc tôi
hỏi nó liên tục đấy đúng không ạ
Và đấy thì mình n giống như kiểu mình
hỏi một con ai có tâm thì nó sẽ trả lời
mình c có tâm mình đưa đề bài đưa yêu
cầu nó mình đưa ví dụ cho nó mình nói rõ
cho nó là tao làm ABC rồi nhưng không
được Tại sao Đấy xong gửi hẳn nó nói
đoạn code đấy để cho nó hiểu hơn hiểu rõ
là mình đã làm những cái gì mình đang
cần những cái gì đấy đôi khi là tôi sẽ
còn gửi cho nó ví dụ là kiểu đấy tao có
một đoạn mẫu như này mày bắt trước theo
để trả lời cho phòng kiểu format như thế
à theo tôi thì có rất nhiều C
mình đảo sâu vào mình hỏi và thường là
chúng ta nên tự hỏi chất vấn chính mình
nữa tôi không biết tôi kể mấy ông chưa
Nhưng mà Gần đây tôi đang phải trả lời
câu hỏi à Tôi là ai một lần nữa tôi cài
càng trả lời dần dần được câu đấy rồi
nghĩa
là kiểu mình là con người như nào mình
mình có đang là con người mình muốn hay
không giả sử Thế mình đang trên con
đường mình muốn hay không Ví dụ Giả sử
Tôi muốn tôi là người đy trí thức các
thứ thứ thì tôi có
đang đang kiểu đang dần dần hành con
người như thế hay không Hay trở thành
một thằng trẻ trâu
hỏi việc hỏi sẽ khiến cho mình có việc
cái cái đặt câu việc đặt câu hỏi đúng ấy
lại khiến mình biết cách để mà tìm câu
trả lời đúng
và và mình khi mà trả lời được đúng mình
trả lời được những cái vấn đề mình muốn
thì có phải là mình sẽ làm được mọi thứ
đúng không
Đấy
Ok cái này Hôm trước Thực ra trong cái
Podcast này tôi nhớ còn một câu nữa mà
Tôi thấy rất là hay Tuy là không liên
quan đến cái tiêu đề các bạn phải nghe
Podcast các bạn biết đó là về quan điểm
về hạnh phúc Ờ tôi nhớ là như thế
Ờ quan điểm về hạnh phúc Tôi không biết
là mấy ông quan điểm thế nào tôi cũng
không Tôi cũng không kiểu bị lý thiết
quá theo kiểu là hạnh phúc phải như a b
c h như xz gì đó nhưng trong đấy có cái
đề cập với cái việc là hạnh phúc mình
không phải nên đi tìm mà nó xuất phát từ
chính mình ấy Kiểu mình cho phép mình
hạnh phúc thì nó sẽ annh Phúc kiểu thế
Nghe nó kiểu bị lý thuyết cũng hơi Seo
HP À ha các TH thứ một tí nhưng tôi thấy
là cũng có tí đúng nghĩa là rất nhiều
Mình mình đôi khi mình đi tìm tất
cả làm rất nhiều cái thứ Bởi vì số đông
làm thế ví dụ Giả sử Giả sử Tôi đang
định bảo hỏi là ở đây có ai FA không ạ
ch có khi tất cả ông hiện tại đang giơ
tay nhưng
mà thực sự là mấy ông
cần có người yêu ở thời điểm hiện tại
không ạ mấy
ông mấy ông muốn có người yêu để làm gì
ạ Hay là vì kiểu lạnh quá thôi muốn có
người ôm hay
là hay là kiểu dạng là thấy mọi người có
thì
thì thì mình nên có kiểu thế nó là giống
việc lập gia đình hoặc là muốn có tiền
chẳng ạn rất nhiều người thường ha trả
lời tôi tôi thấy là khi mà tôi hỏi cái
ước mơ của nhiều người thời điểm hiện
tại tôi tôi gặp Giả sử Giả sử tôi tôi
nói ở góp nhìn tôi nhé Giả sử tôi đi cà
phê
với 10 người để mà thử nghe góc nhìn
quan điểm của họ phải đến tám người tám
người là đều nói ước muốn là
giàu tôi lên ti tục kiểu nghe cái đấy
nhiều và tôi luôn phải hỏi lại
là bạn muốn bạn ước bạn giầu Bạn muốn
bạn giàu để làm gì và thế nào quan điểm
của bạn thế nào mới là giàu sao nhiều
người có nhiều người trả lời lại câu đấy
một cách cũng kiểu chi tiết được nghĩa
là chúng ta bảo à Tôi cũng thấy được Ừ
bạn đấy cũng không không nói việc quan
điểm l đúng hay sai ước mơ mỗi người mà
mỗi người mỗi hoàn cảnh nữa đấy như là
đang nói là có bạn thể trả lời được rõ
cái đấy chứng tỏ là bạn ấy từng nghĩ về
việc nó ấy rồi và bạn ấy Ok bạn
ấy có mục đích rõ ràng để có lý do là
bạn hấy có ương mơ Như Thế coi như là
bạn hể bảo ừ thì tao thấy kiểu
tiền có vẻ giải quyết hay cái gì gì đó
tiền có vẻ có hạnh phúc ho có người từng
nói Tôi kiểu kiểu à à Dạ nhở Tao không
có tiền nên tao ước nó trước đã còn
không biết là khi có tiền thì tao để làm
gì kiểu
thế và quá nửa trong đấy đều không trả
lời được câu giàu thực sự là gì đối với
họ đối với họ
nhé bởi vì Ờ gọi như nào nhỉ ví dụ tôi
hỏi mấy ông nhá Mấy ông cánh Chat đy bây
giờ lên tận 20 rồi tôi không nghĩ là tất
cả cùng nghe đâu nhưng mà Giả sử có hai
ba ông ở đây đang trả lời thì theo mấy
ông thế nào là
giấu hồi trước hồi trước tôi không biết
tôi từng nói mấy ông chưa đó hồi trước
tôi tham gia công ty đa cấp ấy thì người
ta cũng nói có một lần người ta nói về
qu điểm này giàu đó
là đó
là khi mà bạn nghỉ làm Bây giờ
ở Dầu này là dầu tiền nhá không phải dầu
tình cảm Nữu
làm bạn vẫn đủ ăn tiêu đủ kiểu tiêu sinh
như sinh hoạt bình thường như này cho
đến cuối đời thì đấy gọi là giầu bạn
không cần phải
à Cắt bớt chi tiêu hay đủ các thứ nữa
bạn vẫn hoàn toàn thể tiêu sinh hoạt như
bình thường hàng ngày đấy Bạn không cần
phải lo nghĩ về tiền thì đấy gọi là giàu
đấy đấy hồi tôi tham gia công ty đa cấp
nó như thế
bởi vì hồi đấy Người ta cố nói Nhấn mạnh
về cái vấn đề đó là à khả năng kiếm tiền
thụ động à Tức là chỉ là mình nằm ngủ
tiền nó vẫn về tài khoản nên là mình
hoàn toàn hệ tiêu thoải mái không Không
phải kiểu kiểu dạng là không còn kiếm
được thêm tiền chứ nếu mà không kiếm
không đúng nghĩa là không còn kiếm được
thêm tiền thì kiểu gì tiêu chẳng hết
đúng không Nhưng mà đây là không đi làm
nữa nhưng mà tiền nó vẫn về đều thì ch
ra đấy là giấu
hồi mà tôi nghe đa cấp về giầu quan điểm
mà nhiều người tôi từng hỏi về giàu thì
có bạn thì tôi tôi nói rõ hỏi rõ bạn đấy
kì Ok bạn Giả sử bạn muốn giàu tức là
bạn muốn nhiều tiền thế theo bạn thế nào
nhiều tiền một tháng bạn nghĩ bạn kiếm
được bao nhiêu thì sẽ là nhiều tiền
nghĩa thu nhập được bao nhiều nhiều tiền
đấy hoặc là về sau bạn có bao nhiêu tỷ
chẳng hạn thế ở tầm tuổi bao nhiêu thì
bạn coi là lúc đấy là đạt được ước mơ
giầu của bạn thấy Giả sử thế đấy cứ phải
hỏi rõ ra như thế xong rồi rất nhiều
người chẳng trả lời được câu đấy bởi vì
những cái người trả lời được cái câu đấy
người ta không cần phải ước là mình giàu
nữ người ta đi thực hiện mất rồi Có một
sự thật đấy rất nhiều người giàu tôi
biết được là họ không Bao giờ ước là tôi
biết nhé Tôi quen ở nó chứ không phải là
kểu cũng không phải là kiểu là Ờ họ họ
phải kiểu dạng phải ước gì cả họ không
phí điều ước ở điều đấy mà họ vạch ra Ví
dụ Giả sử họ muốn là 30 tuổi họ phải có
tầm vài tỷ trong tay cụ thể 3 tỷ chẳng
hạn đấy Xong rồi họ biết được là một Nếu
thế thì bây giờ tính đến tầm đấy thì mỗi
tháng họ phải kiếm được bao nhiêu hoặc
là à từ giờ đến à năm ha 8 Tuổi là bạn
đấy phải lên cái chức vụ gì rồi Để để
mỗi tháng sau kiếm được bao nhiêu các
thứ Bạn ấy rõ ràng vạch ra toàn bộ kế
hoạch ấy đấy thì bạn đấy kiếm
Ờ tôi đang nói về chủ đề Chắc là để Tóng
tắt lại thì chắc là nói về ước mờ và cụ
thể hơn là cách việc đặt câu hỏi Bởi vì
khi mà đặt họ câu hỏi xong xong các bạn
sẽ tự vỡ lẽ ra khá nhiều vấn
à các bạn đang nói về nghiệm vụ cân sử à
Vừ có từ nghĩa vụ đây đúng không Tôi
không Tôi đề cập ở đây chắc không có từ
nghĩa vụ thì cũng có tí liên quan đ
nghĩa vụ quân sự đấy
à Ừ thì tôi chắc Tóm tắt lại vụ giàu kia
ở đấy nghĩa là các bạn
theo tôi thì mọi vấn đề đôi khi chúng ta
giải quyết được cách đặt kỹ câu hỏi và
đặt đúng câu hỏi kiểu rạng là
ừ Xem thực sự là mình cần cái gì mình
muốn cái gì và và tại sao mình muốn cái
đấy mình cần cái đấy mình làm thế nào để
đạt được cái đấy nó cụ thể là cái gì Ví
dụ mình muốn có người yêu thì cụ thể
người yêu là cái gì người yêu là ai
Người yêu là con trai con gái tầm bao
tuổi tầm kiểu tính cách như nào ngoại
hình như nào đấy khi mình cầm phân tích
dần thì mình sẽ biết được là ừ nên tìm
người đấy ở đâu Đúng không ông Ông không
thể hình như là tôi từng kể mấy ông về
từng khuyên mấy ông V vụ này rồi Mấy ông
không thể tìm được một bạn ngoan hiền ở
trên qu bar Được bạn sẽ hoặc là bạn
không thể tìm bạn ngoan hiền khi bạn Nằm
nhà rồi bạn chỉ ngồi thả Story dạo à thả
team Story dạo được bạn phải chủ động
lên đúng không ạ Bạn hi vọng người ta để
ý nhìn thấy mình thì sẽ phải như nào
đúng không
tiếp tôi ghi cái vụ này lại quyền lợi
trách nhiệm và nghĩa vụ
Ờ Bởi vì tôi nhớ tôi gần đây tôi có đọc
một cái
bài đó là kiểu
trả lời bình luận của một bài đăng nó
khá là thực tế luôn ở bên J2 J2 team
community
à Tôi có bình luận trong bài đấy vì tác
giả khá giống giống tôi và đôi khi có
thể giống anh em mình đó là kiểu cũng
kiểu cũng hơn hai mấy tuổi làm senio
cũng được 3 B năm rồi cũng sắp sắp 30
tuổi rồi lương thì cũng được nghìn đô
rồi nhưng mà thấy
là cạnh tranh nhiều quá Xong
rồi xong rồi Kiểu cũng chuẩn bị sắp thấp
nghiệp các thứ các thứ
Ờ ông đấy thì thường hã so sánh với các
bạn bé ông đấy là đi làm dân kinh doanh
kiếm được nhiều hơn và kiểu thấy là kiểu
mình tự ti Ông ấy bị tự ti đương nhiên
là ở trong bình luận đấy thì mọi người
cũng kiểu so sánh ông đấy với những
ngành nghề khác thì rõ ràng ông đấy hoàn
toàn kiếm đang kiếm được hơn và không
hiểu tại sao ông thứ nhất là cách chi
tiêu ông đấy có vẻ không hợp lý Thực ra
tôi cũng đang như thế Tôi không chê được
thứ hai
là là ông
đấy Làm 3 4 năm lên nghì đô mà ông ấy
kiểu có vẻ kiểu Chắc là chỉ gọi là phấn
đấu được đến thế nên
là kiểu thực ra do nhiều lý do nữa nên
là Khiến ông ấy kiểu không Không phần
đầu hơn ấy bởi
vì Sino vẫn lương vẫn có thể là hơn n000
đô và kiểu 3 4000 vẫn là chuyện bình
là có thể ông ấy cũng chỉ đến cái ng
kiểu tầm tầm như thế và khi 30 tuổi
đương nhiên là chúng ta sẽ khó mà cạnh
tranh được hơn
thì nên như th nào thì ngay ngay từ đầu
là tôi cũng xác định rõ là đến tập 30
tôi sẽ khó mà kiểu ngồi cốt để cầy để
mà
kiểu cạnh tranh được với giới trẻ bây
giờ ngồi cốt x bây giờ còn N các thứ thứ
nữa thì chắc chắn là mình sẽ nghĩ đ
ngành nghề khác không biết được mấy ông
có nghĩ thế không Tôi nghĩ giống như tôi
bảo mấy ông là tôi sẽ không hoàn toàn là
codt nữa mà nhảy sang mảng
à Một là đi dậy này xong rồi làm diễn
giả hoặc là về sau chuyên sâu về bên
database eql các thứ cái bên đấy thì nó
yêu cầu nhiều năm kinh nghiệm nên là
chắc là mình cũng sẽ có thể phù hợp tí
chứ không thuần và kiểu ngồi chạy code
nữa Hôm nay tôi vẫn nhớ là
ờ đồng nghiệp tôi thường hay chê tôi làm
giao diện x rồi tôi mới để do một phần
giao diện tôi tôi làm kiểu tôi cứ zoom
hết cỡ lên kiểu chữ to như này rồi làm
nó diệ xấu vãi chư nghĩa là mình vừa
không gu ở Mỹ mình lại hiểu cũng già rồi
Tôi thường An nói tôi già kìu làm phong
chữ to hết cỡ lên k Thế An kể thế em mấy
ông đang để ý cầu màn hình Tôi đang để
cái trữ to ấy chứ đ phải zoom
lại mình không cạnh tranh được thì mình
biết sức mình đến đâu Và không nên tự ti
không nên đừng nên tự tim so sánh mình
với ai tôi thường hay so sánh mình quá
khứ tôi thấy tôi vẫn đang phấn đấu lên
được và đang đi ở đúng hướng nên mình cứ
cố gắng thôi Bởi vì mỗi khi mình tự tin
như thế Mình không phấn đấu đấy là may
mà ông đấy còn đang vẫn còn đang không
thể nói đang lạc quan nhưng mà nói chung
không Đấy chưa nghĩ vấy cái bi quan
nhưng tôi đã từng
quen tôi đã từng quen rất nhiều người bi
quan các bạn xung quanh các bạn cũng
thấy có đúng không ạ
ờ À đúng rồi Tôi nhớ là tôi có ghi cái
này cũng bởi vì tôi có đọc một bài hôm
nay khá là buồn về một bạn nhảy cầu
vì vì chuyện tình cảm mà bạn ấy còn rất
là trẻ
hơi vì mỗi bản thân mình cái quyền lợi
nghĩa trách nhiệm và nghĩa vụ này đây sẽ
copy cho
m mình dùng CHT để
học thức cả luật pháp nó cũng dựa trên
kiểu cuộc sống hàng ngày của mình tạo ra
thôi nên cũng và chết học Thế nên các
bạn cứ không nên có gì cái gớm đây lợi
ích và ưu đãi của một người Hưng
bỏ qua theo pháp luật đi và theo xã hội
các th thứ đấy
nhá các bạn đang đang sống các bạn đang
may mắn hơn rất nhiều người vì các vì có
nhiều người không Không có mạng để dùng
Xong rồi không được thoải mái mọi thứ
như mình mình tính ra là mình vẫn đang
nói thẳng là mình cũng đang đang gọi là
tận dụng tài nguyên của của kiểu xã hội
của Cn của trái đất vân vân vân vân nên
là nên là tôi nghĩ là ai cũng nên có
kiểu kiểu trách nhiệm sống cho nó đáng
chứ không phải là sống như kiểu hơi hợt
theo tôi như thế Ờ đấy đó đó là đó quyền
lợi là được sống xong rồi được mọi thứ
như bây giờ đúng không ạ tôi không Tôi
không biết được hoàn cảnh cụ thể các bạn
nhưng tôi khẳng định được là có nhiều
người đang hoàn cảnh tốt hơn tôi nhưng
mà suy nghĩ thiếu trách nhiệm và thiếu
trách nhiệm với cả bản thân mình đầu
tiên bản thân mình đã nhưng thứ hai
là là không có trách nhiệm với những
người xung quanh hay là đấy giống như
tôi nói Đây Bây giờ nếu mà các bạn xem
về những
cái video kiểu không phải nói phải video
là kiểu dạng này nhiều người chết đói
hay các th thứ tôi không đề cập đến Nỗ
quá sâu như thế nhưng mà
đang bớt may mắn hơn mình nên tôi cảm
thấy là kiểu mình phải toàn bộ Mình phải
trân trọng điều đấy nên mình phải có
trách nhiệm với rất nhiều thứ theo tôi
là như
thế
Ờ cái Trách nhiệm này nó khác với đạo
đức à với khác à trách nhệ nghiệm này nó
khác với nghĩa vụ này nghĩa vụ đôi khi
các bạn thường ngay th thường là kiểu ví
dụ nãy giờ mấy ông nghe đấy mấy ông đọc
thì mấy ông liên tưởng ngay đến nghĩa vụ
quân sự đúng không ạ thực cả ng nghĩa vụ
nó ôm hơn rất nhiều thứ hơn thế
có trách nhiệm với
Ờ tôi thì tôi cũng TH th nhận là tôi
cũng hơi vô trách nhiệm với à những
người xung quanh vì tôi cảm thấy là kiểu
tôi vẫn kiểu sạ nh thỉnh thoảng vô tâm
rồi các thứ thứ nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là tôi
sẽ ít nhất là tôi sẽ phải có trách
nghiệm với bản thân mình đã lo được cho
bản thân này không để người khác lo lắng
cho bản thân và cảm thấy đấy ví dụ ngay
bây giờ tôi đang thấy là tôi đang cống
hiến có ích này chẳng hạn thì tôi cũng
là làm hoàn thành một phần trách nhiệm
mình rồi nó chỉ mình Có kiến thức thì
mình chia sẻ lại Đấy cũng là một phần
trách nhiệm đấy nhá thôi Tôi nghĩ là
trách nhiệm nó cái từ trách nhiệm nó
mang rất nhiều ý nghĩa
đấy
đy chăm sóc hoặc bảo vệ người khác Và
đôi khi chỉ là bảo là kiểu dạng
là bảo vệ chính mình để mà cho thế sau
này đấy Kiểu thế
Ờ tôi thì tôi hơi phá sức khỏe tí nhưng
mà tôi cũng nghĩ rất nhiều với nó rồi đó
còn tôi phá sức khỏe nhưng mà tôi cũng
biết điều đấy nên tôi cũng không sử dụng
mấy cái kiểu chất kích thức hay là mấy
cái đồ gấy ảnh
hưởng kiểu đến sức khỏe các th thứ không
phải bởi vì nó kiểu dùng nó để cho cho
gọi là cảm xúc nhất thợi vân vân vân rồi
ảnh hưởng thì sau này ít nhất là với
mình đã xong rồi với cả thế hệ sau nữa
càng nguy hiểm nữa
ờ tự nhiên nói mấy cái này tự nhiên nó
hơi bị sâu đíp quá l man quá nhở xin lỗi
Tại hôm thỉnh thoảng tôi bị thế và thình
thảng Tôi đọc những cái bài kia tôi cảm
thấy là
muốn nói qua với nó thôi theo kiểu là
tôi Đôi khi tôi nói cái này là
kiểu chắc không hẳn là để dạy cho các
bạn đâu b vì tôi cũng chẳng a đ mà dạy
các bạn và các bạn cũng có thể chẳng cần
quan tâm chẳng cần nghe nhưng mà tôi Đôi
khi tôi nói về mấy cái đấy nó là quan
điểm của tôi nó cũng chẳng phải đúng
luôn Tôi nói là bởi vì chúng ta hoàn
toàn có thể thảo luận trao đổi chia sẻ
với nhau những quan điểm kiểu Mình gặp
ngoài đời đúng không Ok Mình gặp ngoài
đời xong mình chia sẻ mình kiểu nói
chuyện với nhau thôi tôi đấy là cách
tôi tôi muốn mình hoàn toàn thể cười Mở
tâm sự trao đổi mọi thứ Bởi vì tôi hôm
trước tôi có nói đy nó có rất nhiều
người ở đây có thể là đôi khi là không
có ai để mà chia sẻ chẳng hạn thì chia
sẻ với người lạ các thứ thứ Nó là một
cái hay mà đúng không
Ờ ok tiếp theo là đến cái bài này Hôm
nay tôi mới đọc
được đây là đây tôi sai lầm khi nghĩ
rằng B ha bit là đủ cho toàn bộ địa chỉ
Internet đy người người phát đồng phát
minh ra cái IP tra gần như là mệnh danh
tra đẻ
Internet Thì bạn biết khái niệm về 32
bit không ạ kiểu dạng là cái địa chỉ IP
v4 ấy thì bây giờ đến Nỗ là kiểu
Internet trên thế giới dùng hết mấy cái
giải địa chỉ đấy rồi nhưng mà nhưng mà
cái thời của ông đấy vào năm 1973 ấy thì
cái lượng lượng kiểu 32
bit đã quá khủng rồi và người ta không
hề nghĩ đến là sẽ sau này kiểu sẽ dùng
hết được
đấy Thì bạn này đăng một cái này khá hay
này
này thêm mới nói những Project tầm cỡ và
thay đổi thế giới như vậy có những điểm
mà tác giả cũng cảm thấy chưa hoàn hảo
nên là lỡ code hoặc design module này
service nào
đó cứ ghi nhớ trong team tránh lặp lại
sa lầm về sau và không quá hối tiếp và
dặn vặt bản thân thân Vở Bạn nói câu này
rất hay mang tiếng là bài nghe có vẻ thư
giãn nghĩa ở đây chúng ta sẽ có thỉnh
thoảng có
lỗi chúng ta không nên kiểu có lỗi thì
thứ nhất là chúng ta không nên quá dằn
vặt và hơi tiếc giú kinh nghiệm thứ
hai cũng là đó là đừng nghĩ quá nhiều
khi mà code hoặc design một cái gì đó
đôi khi là nó mình sẽ bị dính vào cái
tình huống uống à kiểu thực ra bài toán
nó không phức tạp đến thế Nhưng mình cứ
kiểu nghĩ đấ phức tạp hóa vấn đề lên
thành ra là kiểu mãi mình không code
được một cái gì đó mà cho dù rõ ràng ví
dụ ví dụ nhá Cái trang web bán hàng như
tôi đang Bảo đang triển khai làm cho mấy
ông này thức ra nó cũng chỉ ở trang web
kiểu cũng tầm trung bé bé thôi Thế nên
là cũng không cần phải design gì đó quá
cá siêu cả nói nói thẳng là th thực Chắc
là vứt hết toàn bộ code vào controller
về sau sửa vẫn được vì về sau nó không
thể phình to lên kiểu Một file
controller đến tận nghìn dòng code cũng
chưa đến cũng chưa thể đến mức độ đấy
được ý nên là cũng không cần phải nhất
thiết phải design gì đó quá ghê gớm và
số lượng người mà động vào cái đoạn code
đấy cũng chỉ có một hai người thì cũng
không cần phải design theo kiểu là gì đó
quả kiểu dạng là thích thì vào sự ai
chẳng biết được kiểu mình đã code cái gì
vào đúng cái chỗ đấy mà sửa không Không
cần phải
kiểu chia chia chia xong rồi các thứ thứ
để tránh file này ảnh hưởng file kia
mình biết thừa mình code đã mình đã code
cái gì đấy Nói chung
là cái đấy là những cái bẫy của lập
trình bẫy lập trình Tức là chỉ là chúng
ta nghĩ quá nhiều Xong rồi khiến cho
khiến cho chính chúng ta đau đầu và
chính chúng ta chùn bước đã u cái đoạn
này gê gớm này nhiều cái này có khi mình
không làm được đâu đấy chẳng hạn thế cho
dù rõ ràng là bài toán nó rất là
quan trọng nữa đó là chúng ta cứ phải
làm trước đã xong rồi chúng ta mới nghĩ
việc tối ưu chúng ta đừng nghĩ việc là
cứ phải design các thứ thứ thứ mất quá
nhiều thời gian và cái việc design thành
ra là kiểu về sau code cũng sẽ rất là
mệt đấy hoàn toàn chúng gọi là chúng ta
phải ước lượng được cái dự án đấy Có nên
làm à Có nên làm design quá chi tiết hay
không Ví dụ đây là ví dụ đây Cái trang
web bán hàng này thì nó là một cái dự án
kiểu chỉ cần Tầm 3 4 tháng làm thôi thì
trong vòng 3 b tháng đấy mình phải làm
hết tính năng chẳng hạn thì mấy ông có
nên dành tậ ba bốn tuần để ngồi làm
design cho code kiểu dạng cho nó hợp lý
các thứ thứ không không chẳng cần
à Ok và tiện thể tôi
kể tôi kể cho mấy ông cái câu chuyện này
ở công ty tôi bị dính
à Tôi từng Hình như tôi từng nói mấy ông
rồi đó là đó là
kiểu các bạn nếu mà làm database các bạn
biết về cột timestamp rồi Ờ nó
cũng dùng 32 bit thì
phải nên là nên là kiểu giới hạn tối đa
của cộ timestamp nó là 2038 nhá Nếu mà
ông nào đang để database mà có cột để
kiểu định dạng là timestamp thì nhớ cái
quả này bởi vì ở công ty tôi này này hồi
đấy là tôi Bọn tôi làm quả cho cột
expire kiểu tăng lên 100 N để nó không
Giờ hết hạn xong rồi bởi vì nó quá giới
hạn nó quay trở lại thành 1970 đấy Nên
là nên là mấy ông kiểm kiểm tra lại xem
DB và có thể dự án của ông có khi không
sống đ đến 2038 để mà lỗi đâu Nhưng mà
nếu Giả sử có thì mấy ông nên đổi lại
kiểu dữ liệu của cột để cột timestamp
thì đến 2038 nó sẽ reset lại 1970
đấy ok
à tiếp theo là hôm nay tôi định sẽ chia
sẻ cho mấy ông về kênh này cái này tôi
thấy hay
phết trong này có gì nhạy cảm không nhỉ
Ừ chẳng có gì nhạy cảm cả Ok Thì hôm
trước là bạn tôi mới bình luận cái kênh
này À đây là trang web mà cho mình tự
tạo lịch để mà người khác có thể đặt
lịch để mà kiểu đặt lịch hẹn hò Đặt lịch
Cà Phê cái gì gì đó với với mình đấy ví
dụ hôm trước tôi vừa tạo này đấy đấy Tôi
vừa tạo một cái lịch cho chính bạn thân
mình đấy bây giờ
khi khi đây tôi copy cái link
Đấy khi người khác bấm vào lịch này thì
sẽ kiểu đây sẽ hiển thị ra
lịch ví dụ là ngày mai tôi trống này Thứ
Bảy Chủ Nhật này không trống này Đấy bấm
vào chọn là kiểu dạng tạng là hai tiếng
ở ở đây nó kiểu cái cái location nó chọ
chọn sơ xài lắm nên tôi ghi mỗi Hà Nội
Trung Trung kiểu anh em ở Hà Nội thì có
thể đặt lịch C thử thứ ví dụ là đặt từ 6
Gi đi
đấy điền tên này email này
thì thì cái vụ đến Email lúc đầu tôi
kiểu tìm cách để tắt email đi vì gì kiểu
Tôi không nghĩ là tôi cần Email các bạn
xô Cuối cùng thì về sau tôi mới mới nhận
ra được chân lý có lý do nó để cái email
này mới ông biết người ta tại sao tự
nhiên nó yêu cầu phải phải bắt buộc phải
điến email không ạ Ông à trả lời được
Tôi cho 10
Điền
nhưng có vẻ mấy ông thế này chắc chắn là
mở của tôi để
A hết nó cũng chấp nhận mà
Ờ thông báo qua mail Quảng cáo đúng rồi
để chuẩn là để thông báo qua mail
đấy mấy ông bị quảng cáo nhiều quá mấy
ông sợ hay sao ấy Nghĩa là nghĩa là ở
đây là
ờ Bởi vì nếu mà giả sử Điền mỗi tên thôi
Sợ Đặt lịch xong rồi thì thì Nếu giả sử
thì ông đâu biết được là tôi đã xác nhận
cái lịch của ông hay chưa nh tôi Hủy cái
lịch của ông thì sao đấy Xong
rồi tôi ở trên này tôi không nhớ là có
cái vụ hủy hay là xác nhận hay không
Nhưng mà có cái vụ dời lịch Tôi nhớ là
thế thì khi rời lịch sẽ thông báo lại có
mail của ông đấy và cái điểm Hay ở đây
là khi mà đọt lịch này xong nhá là nó tự
động thêm vào Google calender của mấy
ông luôn Hay phết Bởi cái này tôi đang
kết nối Google calender để và khi mà giả
sử tôi thêm một cái sự kiện gì đó trên
Google Calendar của tôi là coi như là nó
sẽ tự động kiểu nó nó ở đây nó cũng tự
động đọc nghĩa là nó biết được à hôm đấy
tôi bận và lúc này nên là nó cũng sẽ
không cho người khác đặt vào cái lúc mà
tôi bận tôi thấy hay phết trong này có c
đặt rất là nhiều chỉnh kiểu à tiêu đề
các thứ thứ này mô tả này mấy ông đang
thấy
này chỉnh được là 60 ngày gần nhất cho
đặt thôi không kiểu đấy
à Kiểu chọn được là những khung giờ mình
rảnh
này cái này là
gì
này là BN tiếng trước khi mà sờ đặt thì
phải mỗi ngày tôi chỉ cho đặt một lần
hẹn cà phê thôi chẳng hạn đặt nhiều quá
mệt lắ
Ờ còn thêm mấy cái là điền những cái câu
hỏi này giống như kiểu bạn sợ à Này
Ừ nó còn thu cả kiểu kiểu thu tiền ở đây
tôi không biết bụ thu tiền như nào kiểu
ch đặt thì mất tiền à biết được
Ờ nói chung là nó cho tùy chỉnh nhiều
phết là tôi mới tạo một Tôi cũng tôi
cũng gọi như nào nhỉ
Nên là chắc là cũng nên chỉ tạo một thôi
không nên tạo nhiều đấy tôi chia sẻ link
này trên discord đấy mấy ông hoàn toàn
thể kiểu đặt lịch anh em Hôm nào đi cà
phê
Ờ nhưng mà nói thế Thực ra mấy ông này
boss Hẳng thì hơn nên đặt này cho vui mà
chứ tính ra thì nên B Hẳng để còn ngồi
bàn nhau cho dễ kiểu biết rõ địa điểm
các thứ chức bây giờ đặt qua cái này
đúng nghĩa là đúng nghĩa như này nhỉ ừm
tôi biết được email ông Thôi rồi tôi lại
phải ngồi trả lời Email của ông thay vì
hai đứa ngồi nói chuyện trực tiếp luôn
nó dễ hơn
đen ok
Ờ xong rồi bâ giờ tôi vừa chia sẻ một
cái trông có vẻ hay hay Thằng này bị ng
sĩ
vãy
à không B lỗi gì nữa Ok À
đấy Hôm nay chúng ta sẽ ngồi làm tiếp
hôm trước thì tôi có
hỏi hôm trước tôi có hỏi đứa em Ừ và
cuối cùng vẫn chốt là vẫn chốt là kiểu
làm kiểu
product có thêm cái đã
Ờ Cái giá này th đền sau
đấy Cái này thì là một trong những cái
đầu tiên
à là một trong những cái Tôi động vào
nên thành ra là có vẻ ngon Ơ nhưng mà
đợi ô tí Tại sao thỉnh thoảng vào đây nó
hiển thị này
nhỉ
nhá Hôm trước mất bao nhiêu công để làm
thằng này x cù bây giờ nó vào
kiểu giới
hạn
continue Thôi kệ đi về sau lỗi thì tôi
nhờ đứa em ngồi ngồi sửa chèn thêm cái
khác
vào bây giờ giả
category
cat thêm category này cho vui
đấy nhưng mà product này phải thuộc một
category ở đó chứ nhỉ Ờ đợi tí cái chỗ
để quản lý category rồi
category new
new này Ờ xem
thôi
cho mấy ông hình dung được đi sửa đằng
này nhá u giá định vãi chưa 1000 này ồ
chỉnh cái này à xịn thấy ảnh này
Uầy lộ hết thông tin nhạy cảm rồi chắc
là mấy không nhìn kỹ được được
ờ ảnh ở công ty đi tiền
Ờ giá à quên đây là một đây giá là 20
cành
đi chọn nhiều như
đó đi nội
dung th thường là tôi lên cade đấy tôi
sẽ lên
thứ này hơn à đây vẫn cóp được này
ngon
đó xịn đúng không copy hết Vy
cái tử tế đi bên này có cho tải ảnh
mà
Đấy Thảnh về cho nó tử tế tí
không
đy làm rất chịn chyển chu vậy
mình làm thế này mình không nhận đồng
tiền quảng cáo nào buốn quá
ờ chọn
ạ thì 400 đi Ừ trông cái này tôi Ưng cái
này nhất đấy cái ảnh này không cho xóa
cuu nhỉ kểu chọn xong mày không được xóa
đi quá xịn đấy tiếp theo ừ mã giảm giá
các thứ Bọn tôi chưa làm Ờ màu sắc kích
thước đấy màu
sắc màu sắc này Xám này không thay đổi
tiền xanh này không thay đổi tiền kích
thước này s này không thay đổi tiền kích
thước XL đi đấy mất thêm bây giờ 400.000
th gì mất thêm ba chục
đấy đấy chông có vẻ ổn nhỉ ấn save phát
Hi vọng không lỗi
bùm
rồi đậy tí sản phẩm ơi đâ Xem uây lỗi
lỗi lỗi lỗi lỗi lỗi lỗi xem sửa Thằng
thứ ba đây là post
dừng lại đây thôi Ủa Alo update của tôi
đâu
đều hướng về trang
này
Ui Đây là một trong những cái nhược điểm
đấy Kiểu ông bị điều hướng nhanh quá này
thay vì thông báo lỗi thành ra là kiểu
không biết được mình sai đúng như nào Ừ
đợi tí đợi
tí xem mình xử lý cái này nằm ở file nào
nhá Đấy edit
[âm nhạc]
này Cái thằng này hơi kém phải kiểu như
này à quên cái này file
rồi edit này V các thứ các thứ
Collection bắt buộc phải điền Collection
luôn Đỉnh
đấy m chưởng
robot re
về Uầy ông em làm nay thì không thông
báo lỗi luôn quá đi được cần phải lỗi
người dùng phải tự hiểu đúng
không Ôi giời ơi thế này giởi thật đấy
xem mà
Ừ không nên redirect về kiểu
thế không rect về nữa mình từ code như
nà tôi tự code tệ lỗi
tôi
dùng form ra scp dùng form ra scrip rồi
thông báo lỗi các thứ thứ mọi thứ đây ổn
hơn nhưng mà tôi lười kết hợp việc mình
đã dùng Blade Tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ ở đây
đợi Đợi tí Đợi tí không rect về thì bây
giờ mình sẽ làm
gì mình sẽ in là thành công hay thất bại
vậy
Ờ
controller này mình có à
không Này admin này mình
cóy mình sẽ gọi đến cái thằng
này
ki CH
à Không ổn lắm Nó sẽ miit nhà
đi
Nếu
trong
này ha điểm G để mà tôi sẽ đó trả về lỗi
như
này thì mình mới biết được mình bị lỗi
chứ ông em còn lười quá không tạo
hẳn
này kiểu này mà ông em vẫn nhận được á
đỉnh
thế code kiểu gì đy
Alo thế này nó như này
mà
content slug require nếu mà nếu mà vốn
đã require như này tôi khuyên thật là
trong cái form lúc mà điền điền cái này
này thì mình phải require V chứ không
phải là chứ không phải là kiểu nhảy sang
back end require một đống như thế kiểu
mình đẩy dữ liệu lên rồi mà đúng không
tất cả đoạn này mình nên require cho nó
Ở đây
file
require Read Only đấy require
này slug này require này B code
này
gì cho dù
xem thực ra là tôi cá nhân tôi
thì ở bên admin này thì người dùng nhập
thế nào cũng được người dùng nhập sai
thì
mình thì lên được sản phẩm sai thôi có
gì mình xóa đi hoặc mình ẩn đi nên là
cũng không cần phải bắt chặt với cái
trường hợp là kiểu bắt buộc phải require
như này tôi Tôi không muốn kiểu như thế
lắm để tôi xem
nào cứ xóa đi đoạn này đi
lưu này lưu product này này f data lưu
lại
này option thứ thứ tạo product option
này Sao vừa nãy lỗi nhỉ t điền lại cái
đoạn này
năng đấy
đó copy cũng nhanh phết nhỉ đúng không
rất hợp về đ
CP cấp giao diện đi ă CP ý
buộc phải điền luôn rất
địch xong rồi ở ở đây thì lại lại có thể
defa Gần đây tôi mới được nghe ông ông
anh bảo
giản không cần phải kiểm tra If empty
nhá rất đơn giản như này thôi Thế là
xong cái này mảng rỗng mà mà mng rỗng
thì forx không chạy thôi không cần màu
mè như
này option cũng thế
rồi
đấy xem xem nhá Delete
này không biết lỗi gì đây rob
rob lại cũng mệt
đấy Chuẩn là nếu làm rob này này thì
chuẩn là mình phải biết tận dụng
cái ero của thằng Blade không thì khó
chịu cực nên tôi nghĩ là ha Tôi sẽ sửa
lại đoạn này đi ôi đoạn nhìn đoạn này
khó chịu quá Tôi sửa
dùng để a đoạn này để mà đẩy hết toàn bộ
thông tin lên Xong rồi trả về thành công
hay thất bại thôi chứ kiểu này à Không
Ổn không thấy không Không th ổn thế
à
api respon
chết đây Xóa đạn này À chy c
Ok Ô Này đẩy lên Gì Gì đó th ra nều thế
có file vied đây đây cũng được Thôi để
tính
sau đẩy đường dẫn lên Ừ l lại này nếu có
các thử thử thử thử Ok C thử thử sau đó
thì
này mặc định lỗi 500 thực ra mình chuẩn
Cái này là lỗi 400
thôi Đúng nhỉ 404 thì phải à đâu 404 đâu
tôi xem lại nào HT p
là link không hợp
cả bắt buộc Điền luôn ạ
AR
đi xóa lại
đi
If
data mình chè thêm cái này vào
đấy Ok Không
cái data gì trả về cũng là một cách ở
công ty tôi làm kiểu
này trả về lại suc tr này successful thì
thôi không có data gì trả về CN gì trả
về gì
mình form này khi Điền xong hết C thử
thử
này
e
chm prevent g ý đi Đúng rồi
đấy xem nào rent default để cho form
submit này lấy toàn bộ thông í trong
form này lấy UR này thap này Ok nếu mà
stus bằng sait in ra
điều hướng xịn thế nhỉ Cái này lấy đô ra
đấy ầ này lấy đô ra
này không có luôn
Uầy đ cấp đấy m ông phải không Kêu C
đỉnh
Má rất hợp người lười như
prevent default để không cho sub form
đúng không th
a nhiện mà nghiện lắm
mế không Ơ nếu thế đoạn này mình phải tả
lại Trang à
đấy để nó sẽ chỉ chỉ à đâu Cắt không
được thì sửa lại đoạn
90 À nhầm quên
không đằng đầu ạ Nó vừa thấy không đằng
đầu mấy không thấy không
đỉnh thật
đấy
nh copy đoạn này đi copy lần thứ ba
cho tải ảnh xong copy được nhiều Trang
nó cấm lại mình lại phải mất công làm
các thứ
trước đã ngồi chỉnh chỉnh thứ thứ không
chạy
cười
bấm chạy xem à Bấm chạy trước đã
bùm cái này bắt buộc phải điển À ừ nhỉ
Vậy để Collection bắt buộc phải điền
không thôi cứ Điền một cái gì đó đi s
Ching lâu
ấy Tìm kiếm database ở đâu vậy xem thử
câu truy vấn này không s trị lâu ấy Mình
ở local mà Ủa
server thì cho chết
bấm cập nhật sucit Ầy quá ngon quá đẳng
cấp đúng nhỉ để đề phòng thì sang bên
trang
này đó xịn không quá xịn
đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ sửa thêm một
tí bỏ qua giao diện này nhá
Ờ đây s này không mất tiền thêm XL này
mất thêm
30.000 chỗ này đại phải nó bắt trước nên
tông kiểu này cho đỡ khó chịu thông cảm
đoạn này do tôi làm không thông báo gì
cả Ừ đự nhiên làm gì có thông báo vì cái
to
này đâu phải là của code của tôi đâu Cái
này đâu ra ấ nó cóp code trên mạng từ
đâu ra chứ nhưng mà thôi không sao Tôi
thẽ ghi nhận cái này cũng thế th ra cái
status này đâu ra ấy chứ copy ở chỗ nào
rồi chứ chúng ta ở đây có làm thế đâu
Chúng ta ở đây làm cái là sắ ship bằng
chu kiểu như này mà Nếu có suit như này
cơ mà Đấy lở
ra m shit đấy
nhỉ xem
này p
ở kiểu dạng trang Index Anh nghĩ là
Trang Index
có Còn nếu không thì nó là cái GP tổng
theo kiểu
ờ À đây đây
không Cũng
được Xem
nh
res confirm relad à Không cái này không
này in là kiểu
khác đợi tôi một
tí nhớ là ông em có làm cái đoạn để mà
chè thêm ra scrip
vào
xem không cả nhiều file
cái đoạn gì vì ví ví dụ kiểu thỉnh
thoảng
thấy crate xong đều hướng về rồi xong
rồi Kiểu à thông bán thành công các thứ
ấ đây ví dụ đây
admin h page xem
nhá xem ở đây xem được không nhỉ Xem xem
ở đây xem được không view này không có
nhắc gì file ja Script vào đây xem em là
đây
trang home Index
công vậy chui đâu ra
Này đẩy về cái gì gì đó như này xong rồi
fen Ông đấy nhận diện kiểu gì để mà in
in in
ra Đỉnh quá ông em ngồi codt kiểu bây
giờ mình ngồi không biết được chỗ nào là
chỗ để nhận diện trong một
cái app alert à nà
alert không có
alert
Ồ ông em ngồi cài cái packit này xong
rồi nó sẽ tự động upload khi mà các thứ
thứ thế
ừm
để tôi thử xem nó alert được không
này
à
đình thật Ngồi lưu ngồi gõ
này rất là mệt
cái ao
Ui thế cái này nghĩa gì nhỉ Ủa
rồi ớ ớ
Ủa toàn bộ dữ liệu
tôi chưa lưu à
Ủa có gì đó Sai sai ở đây nhá Tại sao là
490 400000 490
đấy lửa lắm ảnh trong ngại không lấy
được
này đượca rồi
mạ thông báo thành công như th ra là
chưa chưa lưu
được đỉnh
là phải tả lại trang rồi đấy chắc là lý
do ông Em rất thích tả lại trang để mà
ngồi tận dụng được cái vụ alert kia
không sao Mình thiếu gì mình có những
cái thư viện đây mà th viện ở đây
là
à
he
cái thư viện này ở trong kiểu mình thư
viện ja scrip này phải có ở trong mình ấ
nhỉ Mình chỉ phải gọi chứ
nhỉ đã gọi mức độ này rồi mà đúng
không đợi thôi Tí xem composer ch Vision
nhá Đây Sweet alert đây ông em ngồi cài
thư viện này Ok xem thử nhá Xem con xem
nó chắc chắn là nó có file Script rồi
Tôi không muốn cài thêm cái thư viện nữa
làm gì cả đánh dấu cho vui này
Đấy toc comum
này Ừ y này alert cái thử thử alert cái
thử
Cái này gọi được ở fen không nhỉ nó thử
này có phải không
đúng không Tính ra kể chèn một cái thư
viện vào rồi nhưng mà chèn thư viện ra
skip các thứ thứ vào rồi nhưng mà không
tận dụng được nó ở fen đúng
một tí
nhưng mà đến đoạn
sử nh n sucit
nha điều hướng cứ thử thử
luôn xem
đó
xem
à lỗi tôi lỗi
update cười quá
ờ tạ tắt cái ID
ảnh cái ảnh ở đây vào edit Hình như là
lại mất cái đúng rồi lại
mất thì chắc chắn phải sửa vụ này
Ờ là cái ảnh
ấn chẳng có gì xảy ra
cả
tôi Xóa đoạn s Alert 2 à Xóa thư viện
này à Đợi tí Đợi
tí hay chính đó là nguyên
Ừ làm gì có thư viện này nhỉ Làm gì có
assert public đây dis
thư viện này
nhá cài thư viện
Ờ
bùm đó đã
có tại
cái này lên trên cùng đi thông báo tao
cái gì đó
cho dủ cái này không tìm thấy quá
đỉnh
Ơ không tìm thấy cái S 2 thử delete đi
xem à à Thử đổi tên Thi
ta chỉ muốn đổi tên thôi
nó bảo sẽ cập nhật ở trong này à không
Đừng cập
mà Đấy tả trang nào
không ạ Tạm biệt bạn bạn rất tốt
Master tạm biệ
ấn hẳn cái layer C nào chắc đó Tự nhên
đấy rõ ràng thư viện kia có mà thư viện
kia có ra scrip
mà đúng không ạ đấy Vứt cái đoạn này nào
đây đổi đâu
xem Thế thì cái
này
Ừ vật cái key này trong này đây sẽ
mxit bằng C đoạn này
cần
đấy không cần đây
sẽ mình sẽ
có
m
bằng data
hỏi lấy cái này kiểu gì mà thôi à đâu
vẫn phải in là lỗi chứ nhỉ thông báo lỗi
chứ nhỉ
biến ra scrip
nhưng mà biến ja scrip mà sao nhúng được
vào trong pp
bằng biến này
Đợi tí Đợi
tí tôi thử chạy cái
này tại trang này tô thử chạy này xem nó
in ra cái
Ờ in ra cái gì
đã trong trường hợp là
session như này này
nhỉ Kiểu code kiểu này không được rồi pp
nó không chạy sau
khi
ừ
à Không sao Không sao data ở đây được mà
trả về
If data ở đây xong rồi lấy biến từ
system Đúng không
nhở hình như vẫn là
đi xa quá đ rồi đây cuối cùng thì chung
quy lại mình vẫn phải tải lại cái thư
viện này rồi
Ờ xin lỗi xin
này
Master chè lại thư viện
ơ
có gọi cái này bình thường mà nhỉ
[âm nhạc]
Ừ Chứng tỏ ông em chạy cái đoạn kia san
kia nó còn không chạy
là
này như này một cái thì như
suit Tôi nghĩ là kiểu này chạy
được tôi có niềm
tin làm hơi vất V mỗi cái giao
công này Ừ in là một cái gì đó thực ra
nên tấm cái này vào trong một cái đây
một cái My Custom
alert
à nh alert
này đây rồi thằng suit alert này dụng
đây
đấy à mình còn bị ngược ạ m chưởng
và đây sẽ là
El
Ok tả lại
thông báo thành công hay thất bại ạ Đúng
là ngồi căn căn chỉnh giao diện này tôi
thấy tốn công hơn việc ngồi làm backend
bend tôi vèo vèo rồi
lại nhỉ
À à thiểu chữ js ở đằng đầu
mà dùng p chèn vào giữa anh nhỉ À anh
muốn tận dụng bởi vì bạn kia dùng cái
thư viện toast đấy rồi thì anh muốn tận
dụng
thôi chứ bây giờ cài thêm một cái kiểu
chen thêm đấy vừa rồi phải tải thêm cái
về nó bị buốn cười
Ơ có
Custom
vãi chưởng cái My Custom này Không chèn
vào mà nó nằm trong này à Ầy Cái này
dùng ở đâu đỉnh
như nào cho gọn để sử dụng lại component
về ạ Ờ thực tế là cũng không cần nhất
thiết như tôi đã nói thì cái ví dụ cái
dự án này tôi đang làm thì được các
không cần phải tách ra nhỏ nhỏ thế n tôi
cũng sẽ không
làm Nói chung
là vẫn not
hay Cái này còn không được chạy sao
Custom lại là Min nhỉ đợ tí đợ
sai à đ ra Min
à Đây á
ơ cái thằng này chứa thằng này à chứa cể
gì đỉnh ấy không biết khái niệm này
này chè th chè cái My Custom ở trong này
nó không động động vào
nó một thằng là My Custom bỏ ch Min
Ok có tận hai
nhìn quá như này thôi còn thêm quả Min
nữa thằng này chứa thằng này kiểu gì anh
chưa biết luôn mà thằng này có Min đâu
bịt lừa
chạy đ này Sa khá nhiều công
cuối cùng cuối cùng là chạy được anh em
ạ quất đi thử
nhá yeah lỗi rồi lỗi Đúng không ha không
chạy nữa tắt đi Yeah không chạy nữa
require cho cái này thành ra bị lỗi Tôi
nghĩ tôi tắt xừ mấy cái require Bây giờ
tôi cũng bắt đầu hiểu Dần Ông em kiểu
Tại sao
require không để require
đấy xem name
nà mình dùng a rồi chúng ta không chơi
require nữa đấy lỗi thì mình hiển thị ra
sau
đống này rất mất công
luôn còn phải ngồi chỉnh cái này nữa Tí
tôi sẽ nhờ ông em đang ngồi nói chuyện
nãy giờ để hỗ trợ tôi cái quả giao diện
này tôi tuyệt vọng rồi th lỗi lỗi lỗi
này à Nếu mà lỗi kiểu như này nó còn
không vào kia cơ
lỗi kiểu 500 này À cái này nó khác shit
một cái gì
đó pho đi nhưng mà lỗi 500 này nó còn
không nó sẽ không bắt được ở fanel theo
kiểu bởi vì nó đâu còn là sắ xit
nào Anh live th như thế này dành thời
gian đâu cho người yêu á thì không có
người yêu đỡ phải dành thời
gian đúng không Uầy Cái này làm gì
pending lâu ấy à Nhờ thì bả server chết
nhỉ
À được đó Ok ngon rồi đấy xị rồi mình kê
luôn cả tter quá
Trông trong codt hơi đều đều một tí
nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là cũng gọi tạm ổn rồi
cả buổi chỉ ngồi chỉnh sửa mỗi hiển thị
thông
mình mất gần tiếng đồng hồ chỉ ngồi
chình Sửa thông báo sau tự nhận mình là
xio tôi rút lại tôi chỉ là s
backen tôi là F vanen đ không ạ Các bạn
tôi không biết được các bạn nên học hỏi
vụ b f của tôi hay không À đúng rồi Bây
giờ tôi sẽ như hôm trước tôi h sẽ cần
phải hướng dẫn cho các
bạn có cả vụ của
này cách đẩy đẩy code lên kiểu dạng là
comit các thứ thứ
đẩy comit đẩ code hiểu cái mic các thứ
các thứ
Ờ thường là tôi còn chẳng có giờ ghi vào
cái description này thường là chỉ mess
commit thôi Ờ thì
có nói chung là thực ra là cái để comit
này còn liên quan đến phụ thuộc cái dự
án của các bạn phụ thuộc Tức là sao
nghĩa là nếu giả sửa dự án các bạn rất
là chuyên nghiệp ví dụ bạn làm công ty
to Chuyên nghiệp thì đôi khi đôi khi các
bạn phải có m s cẩn hận các bạn sẽ phải
chọn từng cái dòng như này chẳng hạn chứ
không phải là cả một file ví dụ ví dụ
Giả sử đây đấy chọn những cái đoạn này X
commit là import cái gì thư viện gì gì
đó
đấy Đấy đấy là thực sự là nếu mà các bạn
muốn để để sau này sau này Các bạn nhìn
lại nhìn vào dòng này kiểu Ờ nhìn dòng
này
à Bạn ABC thời gian này đã từng đẩy cái
dòng này lên với nó là gì đấy Đấy là một
kiểu Ờ kiểu thứ hai đấy Kiểu rất cẩn
thận tôi không làm thế tôi chưa từng vào
công ty nào Làm thế
Ờ kiểu thứ thứ hai đó là thường là tôi
cũng thường hay làm đó tôi sẽ commit
theo cả một file như này tôi không ngồi
Chọn từng từng cái đy nhên cũng ngồi xem
tham khảo lại xem hết toàn bộ cột như
này tôi chọn cả một file Nếu mà lười thì
ấn như này thằng đứa em tôi sẽ rất gét
điều đấy vì nó tự động sinh ra cái đoạn
code vô nghĩa à comic vô nghĩa này
cập nhật ví dụ là Factor một cái gì gì
đó Vân Vân
Vân liên quan đến Cập
nhật cập nhật product đúng không ạ Đấy
kiểu thứ hai là kiểu Tôi đang làm ở công
ty
nhưng nhưng ở đây nó vẫn bài toán nhưng
nhá đó
câu hỏi đó là cái commit message ấ Để
làm gì Để làm gì đã
ví ví dụ ví dụ là để để mà nói là để để
mà nói nhé là chuẩn chuẩn là các bạn một
là như tôi vừa nói là phải comit cẩn
thận là từng dòng này các bạn làm để làm
gì Để người ta nhìn vào về sau nhìn biết
được à bạn làm cái dòng này để làm gì gì
đó chứ việc là bạn comic cả một cái file
to như này thì thực ra là cái Message
của bạn nó chỉ C refactor như này chẳng
hạn đấy product này thì về sau người ta
đọc được kiểu Ôi mày thay đổi cả cái
đoạn logic này rồi cùng kiểu ngắn gọn
kểu Factor tạo chẳng hiểu được
là mày làm những cái gì đấy Tại logic
nào để khiến mày làm điều này
đấy Nên là cái cái Cách thứ hai của tôi
Tôi đang nghĩ là nó cũng hơi gọi là hơi
kiểu gọi là cũng gọi là có commit
message nhưng mà nó Thực ra nó cũng
chẳng để làm gì cả thì Cách thứ
nghĩ nhá là ví dụ Giả sử Giống như là ở
công ty tôi đi thì nó
là nó nó nó là theo kiểu
là
đẩy đẩy rất nhiều
file chọn rất nhiều cái như này kiểu gần
như là đẩy trong một đợt ấy xong rồi nói
cụ thể là toàn bộ cái đống file đấy ví
dụ ví dụ giả sử như th này product này
toàn bộ những cái gì liên quan product
này đấy Chẳng hạn giả sử như
này refactor product update như này x
tôi đẩy đoạn này lên đúng không Nếu mà
có lỗi gì đó xảy ra thì tôi sẽ biết được
là reverse lại toàn cái commit này là
được Kiểu là reset lại commit này là
được đấy Kiểu thể thế nghĩa không phải
chọn một file nữa mà chọn nhiều cái và
bản chất là code là kiểu Xem lịch sử
lịch sử đấy ấ đ như này này chứ thực ra
là mấy cái kiểu như này nó hơi bị vô
nghĩa Tôi nói thẳng là kiểu Cái này mới
có message này Thực ra cũng chẳng đểm gì
hơi vô
đợt cả một cục như này và khi reverse
thì reverse cả cục ờ
cũng là một
cách chứ còn nếu mà chuẩn ra ấy chuẩn ra
để mà mình đọc meit để mà hiểu được là
xem là tại sao lại có logic đoạn đấy thì
mình sẽ phải comy cẩn thận không hẳn là
từng dòng nhưng mà nó cũng phải cả cụm
một cụm này ví dụ ví dụ Giả sử này đây
cụm này này
là update
a
form product này Đấy đẩy đoạn này lên
này x tiếp theo đẩy đoạn này lên nữa đấy
Kiểu là kiểu đây ví dụ đẩy xong rồi Đầy
đoạn này lên nữa này remove command đấy
rất cẩn thận kiểu kiểu như này Đấy chuẩn
chỉ là mấy ông phải làm như thế thì mấy
ông về sau mới gọi là Xem message để
hiểu là à ông Ông ngồi trước code cái
đoạn này Tại sao lại code Tại sao lại
code như thế đúng không
ạ nhưng mà nhưng mà Thì như tôi vừa nói
là nó liên quan phụ thuộc vào dự án của
ông nữa ví dụ Giả sử có mình tôi code
cái dự án này việc gì tôi phải tôi biết
thừa được tôi chắc là tôi cũng nhớ được
Lý do tại sao tôi phải code như thế còn
nếu mà không nhớ được Lý do tôi có như
thế thì tôi cũng phải xem lại bản thân
mình đấy nế là tôi thường hay làm theo
kiểu là đẩy theo cả cụm như này và ghi
thì cũng chỉ ghi V tắt là kiểu Ừ thì
mình sửa mình cả cụm này sửa liên quan
đếng cái file nào đấy để mà khi mà
reverse code thì mình chỉ reverse lại cả
cả cụm này đi cùng một cái đợt logic ra
được bởi vì hôm trước bởi vì hôm trước
chưa comit code nên thành ra là kiểu hôm
nay mình cũng sẽ lại phải phân biệt xem
code nào code hôm trước C nào code hôm
nay trông cũng hơi loạn nên là thường là
các bạn nếu mà áp dụng như cách ba này
thường là các bạn ngày nào khi mà code
xong các bạn phải đẩy lên kể cả đẩy lên
thường là nếu mà kiểu chưa làm xong ấy
các bạn có thể kiểu ghi à
wp Này work in progress thì phải nghĩa
là kiểu đang làm dở cái phần gì gì đó
Đấy là một cách kiểu các bạn đẩy lên bởi
vì có thể đẩy code lên ở công ty rồi về
nhà ngồi làm tiếp đấy Kiểu thế
à đẩy đấy thì cách tôi đang nói là tôi ở
cái công ty kiểu
tấm vừa vừa và nhỏ thì thường là đẩy cả
cụm này lên còn nếu mà ở công ty chuần
chỉ thì các bạn nên áp dụng cách một đó
là chọn kiểu cũng tương đối một lượng
dòng Nhất định xong rồi kiểu ghi rõ là
tại sao mình làm
thế ghi rõ thế thôi nhưng mà không biết
được là ai đọc hay không nhưng mà chắc
chắc là người sao đọc chứ không hẳn là
mình mình cũng mình thì đương nhiên hiểu
được mình đã cố gì
refactor update
Có thể đẩy K này tạo i5 nhanh này
đấy
logic thì tôi chỉ chỉnh sửa reformat lại
thì tôi sẽ chỉ ghi là reformat à Cái này
liên quan đến kch
Đăng nhằng đấy Cái đoạn này liên quan
đến cả kch nữa cộc chung lại vậy xem
page như này cũng được thế này cũng
tương đối rồi Index nữa chắc
này format
commit fan rất là hời hợt thì tôi làm
chủ yếu
B dụ đây upd 3 này
Đấy sẽ update kiểu rất hơi hợt ph luôn
Ờ gì nhỉ
đó Hôm nay thực ra Tính ra
nhưng mà trong một buổi Tôi nghĩ là cũng
chỉ tầm một tiếng để ngồi cốt
thôi
Ờ một tiếng đ ngồi cốt các thứ thứ và
ngồi tâm sự chia sẻ nói qua một vài cái
thôi chắc là buổi hôm sau tôi sẽ ngồi
quốt nhiều hơn tôi cảm thấy là tiến độ
này có vẻ hơi chậm Chứ ngồi thỉnh thoảng
có một tiếng để làm xong rồi Ngồi chỉ
ngồi sửa mỗi giao diện chắc là tôi sẽ
phải nhờ ông em ngồi sửa giao diện Lại
hết một vài cái đng này để tôi làm back
end cho nó nhanh CH cho nó đẩy tiến độ
lên tí Ừ có gì không
nhỉ Ừ nếu mà các bạn không có câu hỏi
thì chắc là hôm nay tạm nghỉ tại đây nhá